the horizon fm radio station in wagga
dugo
at the microphone civil rights activist
and reggae lover asibi johann gives his
thoughts free reign
to pass my message across to people
here i can express myself freely
for me radio is the voice of freedom
has come to embody freedom for many
people in burkina faso
here he's meeting with senegalese civil
rights activists
earlier this year congolese intelligence
officials imprisoned them after they
spoke at a civil rights congress
so there's a sense of relief as the
activists reunite in wagaduku
we met in a hotel in congo we were
invited to a conference on civic
involvement
they said they were from en
ammar i was excited to get to know them
we then performed together at the
conference and were together in jail
today is the first time we're meeting
again
asibi has invited the senegalese
activists to take part in a meeting of a
local citizens group called
balier sito yen in a suburb of wagadugo
the members are glad to have visitors
together they shout the group's slogans
it has to be possible to do away with
slavery
we have done that it has to be possible
to end colonization
the africans have done that and it also
has to be possible to stop those
presidents who want to stay in power
forever
the group aims to improve the lives of
local people
they spent a whole day collecting a huge
pile of rubbish in the suburb karpala
they explained to the market women why
garbage shouldn't be left lying around
that's very good we believe that
cleanliness and hygiene is good for all
of us
they've now donated four garbage cans to
help the situation
it's hardly enough but good for
publicity through social media
later on they're setting up a solidarity
concert in the evening it's open air and
free of charge for members and
sympathizers
this is a concert for freedom i've been
invited to sing for freedom democracy
and human rights
because that's what i stand for
it's a great platform for civvy and his
band to play their music
but more than that the activists want to
use their concerts to spread their
political message to other countries
please